den and grogu had a whale of a time in
the season 3 premiere of the Mandalorian
but seriously it was with the whales
here's all you need to know
in what felt very much like an RPG we
weren't playing this week's return to
the world of the Mandalorian saw
dingarim returning with old friends and
making new enemies while the child
continued to be adorable
come again his name is grogu
you say so we were also given a slew of
stunning sights from a giant Dinosaur
turtle attack to a crew of familiar
droids mess one of the biggest
highlights though was a moment that our
helmeted hero didn't even see on the way
to Navarro City Mando shifted into
hyperdrive leaving grogu to take in the
blurry view passing at light speed
nothing new for Star Wars here though
something caught that little guy's opal
eye that made baffle some audiences
space whales giant tentacles space
whales and a partner just casually
flying alongside din's N1 Starfighter
without a care so what are these immense
organisms and could they be friends or
foes for our Bounty Hunter and his young
Ally there's a high chance it will be
the former considering the earlier
appearance in the Star Wars Universe
while we only got a peek at their
Silhouettes there's a good chance at the
passersby to grogu and din in this
week's episode of the Mandalorian but
most likely per Gil a species of space
whales that appeared in the final season
of The Beloved animated series Star Wars
Rebels the fourth season showed told the
story of Ezra Bridger who joined a group
of rebels aboard the ghost to strike
back like so many others against the
empire when they grow like that they're
about to jump into hyperspace in Rebels
Ezra A Gifted Jedi in the making uses
the per Gil in A Brave stand against
Amaral thrawn which while relocating the
ghastly Empire goon to an unknown spot
accidentally snapped Ezra along for the
ride as well with his whereabouts are
known the series ended with the
remaining Rebels Sabine Ren and Ahsoka
Tano this was five years before Anakin
Skywalker's former Padawan would cross
paths with Mando and grogu in the
Mandalorian with that in mind there's a
chance at grogu's whale watching isn't
just a fun Easter egg but a nodded some
future action that might bridge the gap
between these two shows in a very
exciting way if your show is being
watched over by law loving Legend Dave
filoni you don't just drop a pot of
space whales into a Star Wars story for
the sake of it the trippy migration
moment that only grogu witnessed could
indeed be a simple tease to the return
of Ezra to the Star Wars universe and
his debut to the live-action side of
things while it was reported back in
2022 that imanis fandi was set to play
Ezra in the upcoming live-action series
Ahsoka what are the odds that we might
see him sooner than that it's nothing
new to see the legendary to Gruta appear
in other shows popping up in both the
Mandalorian and the Book of Boba Fett
with that in mind what are the odds that
we could be reunited with Ahsoka and
Sabine Wren on their search for Ezra
here it'd make for a great little link
into the upcoming show and serve as a
nice introduction for those that might
not be up to date on Star Wars Rebels
plus who doesn't love space whales
no